[Music]
in lier lioness on fire so we define
mama cute Oh a wood line on a resume to
land a job but now she's going to jail
everybody
what did she lie about oh maybe it's a
government Justin everybody lying there
isn't she probably I have a college
degree and we know women don't go to
college
oh that's became handle stress I know I
didn't you didn't go
no I did I didn't graduate Oh cuz they
didn't let women graduate no that's cuz
the Mexican side kicked in Oh see when
so many things are battling within you
the DNA just holds you back
I know a mexican chick who graduated
from college you don't say well she's
not here today so whatever - hey so this
woman good jugs developing this woman
lied and faked her glowing references
she even had her references like be
redirected for her to answer the phone
and she would be her old boss oh sure
what kind job be she's a good voice
actor so her name is Veronica she's 46
from Australia and so she landed a
high-paying job she was getting an
annual salary of two hundred and seventy
thousand Australian dollars which is a
hundred and eighty-seven or eighty-five
thousand US dollars one hundred
eighty-five thousand worth and she
started not knowing what was going on
they were like actually yeah yeah well
what was she doing like what was the
juicy it was a it was an australian
regional government jobs where she was a
job or she was a chief information
officer sure what if she saw the
position she goes I know a lot of
information I can be an information
officer I could be the chief of it yeah
it sounds pretty up there
yeah well the chief part yeah how did
you even [ __ ] the interview dude I
know
exactly
she must be really good so she ended up
there saying that she was able to work
for about a month or over a month and
she ended up earning two twenty two
thousand five hundred US dollars before
she got fired good job so she cutting it
up for a month
mm-hmm I thought they were like you know
what she doesn't have that much
information let's look into her no
because like that whole thing is like -
I mean so she ended up like her life
started coming through because people
started seeing how she was performing
and like home the stress got to her it's
a position it's all easy [ __ ] I can't
take this [ __ ] it's goes we just we just
have to go to the mailroom though it
goes I know but I just don't know where
it is the information I know I hope is
harder than that if there make it to her
so they're saying that she ended up
hiring her brother despite him lacking
the qualification to perform a role that
she hired him for two frames with lack
of informations better than one really
yeah two people they can [ __ ] up now
exactly no but so yeah like they people
were saying that she became suspicious
because of her mental health
deteriorating after starting the
position him seemed so sharp though with
the resume and you know overconfident
like yeah I can do this it's more than
just hard
holy [ __ ] okay so TIFF one of my pet
peeves when I'm sitting in the host
chair is when somebody asks a question
like this but I have a question about it
because it's deadly not in the article
what do they say what kind of duties
that you had to perform in this yeah oh
that's important stick what stressed her
out right you know what do we know what
company she worked for yeah it was for
South Australia's Department of the
premier and cabinet that does not
possession
more even more questions now yeah you
know I mean but yeah so they're saying
that she even used Kate Upton as her
LinkedIn profile photo now she's getting
dumb likes dad's going also she showed
up the day of it she wasn't fine in
there like where you're lying
80 pounds heavier and your hair's black
yeah yeah so she ended up she was
sentenced to at least a year in prison
or this probably she did plead guilty
and they're saying that she's receiving
a 25 month sentence with a non-parole
period oh my god so [ __ ] yeah so she
is convicted of deception dishonesty and
abuse of public office oh and guess what
this was not her first rodeo done this
twice before twice yeah other government
jobs or just I don't know what they were
but they're saying that she had false
information to obtain employment at two
companies in 2012 and 2014 so she had
wonder she has no past references and
she has to answer the phone and those
people Jesus yeah so uh heard like the
defense said that she was deeply ashamed
and embarrassed by the river because she
got caught for the fifth time not sorry
enough to stop [ __ ] doing it but then
also they said her crimes involved a
unique set of circumstances that were
unlikely to be repeated I promise that
the next time I do this I'll do better
yeah
[Laughter]
I will not use Kate Upton that's when
the judge is like and that's what I want
to do so yeah that's how she ended up
getting at least a year have you ever
lied during a job interview no I realize
I should have yeah because a lot of
people do they don't give up and then
also the college degree thing like most
places they don't do well but you could
write Harvard if you want to and they're
gonna go oh you would Harvard alright
cool so how much experience do you have
in this field
right they don't give a [ __ ] I joined
the Marine Corps what there
really light was my recruiter with my
for me oh cool cuz we'll be filling out
the thing of like so this computer says
have you done any illicit drugs before
but what I'm gonna ask you is do you
remember if you do any illicit drugs and
I'm like I can't say I remember that I
did Wow okay
all of them you would like just help me
kind of like sugarcoat and Bend things
like do you solemnly swear all the
things that you remember up here like I
said I remember saying yes and they
catch you and you're like oh that wild
nah I do don't remember but there was a
wild night that happened good you're so
good with loopholes and [ __ ] cuz your
mom things like that you had your
recruiter be like that yeah it's a weak
example my mom was just the best at it
your mom is genius like in a funny way
because she's so loophole II but she
doesn't have logic so it's like how the
[ __ ] is this person so smart when it
comes to figuring out how to crack and
hack things and systems and rules but
then she doesn't think in a way that's
like and she drives your dad crazy cuz
your dad's hella logical yeah but it's
yeah it's [ __ ] weird did you do any
recreational drugs in bora-bora I did it
what would they do
I know but now we can talk about Bora
Bora can you touch numbers I am not
rational no I even kissed a stingray
what they told do they tell you to do
that are you just like huh goodnight
well she had to get somebody she's alone
it's ass being is on the top and I
kissed her three times because it was
really funny so I was vlogging and then
I didn't realize that it was not
recording oh and so like when I kissed
for the first time and then I had to
record it again and then I was like oh
bring this listing right back cuz then
they hold them from the mouth and like
bring up oh oh Alzheimer speaking over
know like the guidance Alda and then so
I kiss it again but then the water like
touched the GoPro thing and so it like
when I was facing it it had like the
system's preferences thing so I'm like
[ __ ] would they not recording again I
didn't kiss him again Jesus Christ no he
was so cute cousin after that he was
like he was like a cat like petting me
like with him like he's gonna stay on
then they kill Steve Irwin yeah
why are you making out with of them I
wasn't making out with well you don't
mean what their other animals you made
out with yeah I I didn't make out with
them but then one of the clarify but one
of the guys he found an octopus in that
same like think you can you let it [ __ ]
you this is my very last day know what a
Japanese think Japanese that's
respectable okay thank you
no so actually if you put it on my
shoulder or I was holding it and I was
walking and then I have huge I was
trying to put it on my chest actually oh
did it change colors because those
things sometimes you change clothes
though no I do get them on my shoulder
and if I got a photo like this and then
you eat it after okay tonight we're
gonna have dinner
I'll come there's so many animals there
is it like part of a reserve or a reef
or something no so
Mora is so if there's like a mean island
and then on the outskirts it's like yeah
like uh like a coral reef
well there's coral there but it's the
entire lagoon so there's a [ __ ] ton of
coral reefs everywhere yeah and there's
just a whole bunch of baby animal comes
with the handler no this is in the wild
yeah but how do you get the fingers in
the mouth of the stingray because they
just know the humans already they these
are frequented visited spots yeah in the
island yeah yeah they already got used
to like in any time that boats come
around they know like oh it's food Chum
time cuz like the the guides have like I
got this one I haven't reviewed the
footage yet but I got this one foot shot
where we were snorkeling and then this
guide he had he was like throwing food
near me as I was swimming so I was
surrounded by a [ __ ] ton of fish it was
so cool I did that when I puked in
Hawaii from choking on the water there
was a lot of fish that came out of
nowhere yeah I was choking and I was on
the paddleboard like [ __ ] trying to get
this water out of my lungs and I [ __ ]
puked and then David said oh this fish
started coming out and all that
Oh get the camera oh yeah that's cool
because you introduced that wildlife to
Starbucks muffin music there ain't some
sous vide bites right there did you wake
up you're like it's cuz you're on the
water it so you wake up you walk outside
you just go right in the water no meats
it oh yeah I could do that
what as soon as like from my bed I just
turn look over to the window and blah
there's paradise right there every
morning I woke up and I'm like oh my god
I'm actually here I had like pinched
myself be like holy [ __ ] I'm not
dreaming right now I'm really punch that
big for you and your hands like more boy
1 I so I'm imagining the toilet just to
be a hole and then you just take it a
dump and the sharks are eating it right
there exactly paradise or it's like a
glass war and you're sitting down and
you just taking bones for my birthday
and they had like you know the whole oh
I got to see fish yeah
the floor they had like a glass thingy
and when they had corals they see it was
amazing guys you guys have to go are you
gonna go back again in my lifetime I did
most definitely would like to alone or
with Casey maybe I don't know again
listen it's expensive but I did find out
cuz like our snorkeling tour guide he
like when we were going on the boat or
on the lagoon he pointed out to some
condos and he was like you could rent
those condos for two thousand for the
whole week and I'm like oh coming back
that's it yeah cuz it's like it's like a
thousand a night for one of those over
the water but mullahs are actually more
I think it's more holy yes Dudley Moore
and the food's expensive this [ __ ]
everything in the islands expensive
because everything is imported
[Music]